تشويق النفسي حتى اخر لحظاته فيلم عصري
ناقش مفاهيم الصحه العقليه وتاثيرها على
المجتمع فرحها البعيد عن الفرح فيلم يعد
جزءا منها اثر وثقافيه في الشرق الاوسط
ستطاع الفيلم الفوز بجائزه العمل الاول في
مسابقه الفيلم العربي بالدوره 38 من
مهرجان الاسكندريه السينمائي لافلام البحر
المتوسط وجائزه النقاط في مهرجان تشيلسي
السينمائي في الولايات المتحده وجائزه
افضل فيلم روائي في مهرجان الفيلم
اللبناني في كندا تبدا القصه التي تروى
بمنظور النساء معاناه طالبه الطب لينا
معكم وبس متكرره حاده تسرع حياتها في
التداعي ثم تضطر العوده الى وطنها لتنطلق
لينا في رحله كشف شبكه من الاسرار
العائليه على كليه في الاستوديو بطلت في
الفرح عطا الله ممثل يوسف اهلا بكم
صباح العربيه
طب همم ستيفاني همم اسم الفيلم فرح لكنه
بعيد كل البعد عن المعاني الحقيقيه التي
كلمه خصوصا في المشاهد الاولى كلهم هيارات
عاطفيه ونفسيه ونوبات عصبيه حدثيني اكثر
عن فكره الفيلم وهي فكره جديده دراما
مضبوط هلا همم مضبوط اسم الفيلم فرح وانا
يعني يمكن ما كثير بوافق الراي انه كثير
بعيد عن الفرح لانه كل واحد عم بيفتش على
الفرح بالنهايه وهايدا مسيره شخصيته
فرح عم بتفتش على الفرح واسيك كل واحد لما
يكون بده يوصل للفرح بالحياه بده يقطع
بمراحل يمكن مش كثير حلوه يمكن
في مشاكل
اليوم لما يتم اختيار موضوع الصحه النفسيه
ولما بنحكي انه المثل هلس بحياتنا هل نشعر
انه احنا كعالم كعرب من قلل من قيمه اهميه
الصحه النفسيه اصلا في حياتنا بالتالي مثل
هيك افلام ممكن تبرز اهميه هذه المساله
صراحه ما فينا نكون عم نحكي بالاجماع انا
برايي انه في كراديتش لازم نعطيها للجيل
الجديد وللشباب العربي همم
الاستاذ همم بطل موضوع الصحه النفسيه مثل
قبل
الفتحه وخصوصا بعد كل شيء صار الناس كلها
بحاجه الى همم
تلاحق الصحه النفسيه
موضوع الصحه النفسيه بخير
وهي يلاقي نسبه مشاهده عاليه لانه الموضوع
صحه النفسيه الي طارحينه مطروح بطريقه
كثير جديده ومش مطروحه من قبل الحديث عن
النجاح يوسف فرح حصتي اشاهدت النقاب بسبب
يعني احترافيه اداء اكل الدور يعني لغه
جسد صعبه انهيارات
اكثر عن تجربتك
همم تجربه صعبه للصراحه همم ما كان ابدا
هيني من اول ما قرات السيناريو حطيت ايدي
على قلبي يعني قلت ان شاء الله يارب
بطريقه الصح
لانه ما بدنا نظلم اشخاص يمكن يكون عم
بيحضروا
يمكن اعراب لما سيرتها الشخصيه همم اديتها
بطريقه همم يعني عملت
ومن كل قلبي
حياتك اليوميه مع اصحابك وهيك ماشي بس انه
بكواليس التصوير اااه
اسم الله علي يعني عملت دور فعلا
يرفع له القبعه وهذا الشيء راح ينشف على
الشاشه
برايي الممثل المحترف همم ما بياخذ ما
بياخذ الدور معه على على البيت همم
استفاني اخذ اللي عم تحكيه هي انه اخذ
معها وقت لا تطلع منه لانه فتره التحضير
لفتره التصوير
دور صعب ومركب كتير
بمعرفه الشخصيه لها ما بيشبعها ولا اي
طريقه همم كثير كل البعد عنا ف- همم
على همم
كاميرا عم بادي دوره برات الكاميرا انا
برجع يوسف في شخصيتي حكايات
مدارس تمثيل يعني في ممثلين هن ببحثوا على
انه الشخصيه ترفقهم حتى برات السات لحتى
يطفشوا للاخر
فبيختلفوا شوي الامور من المدرسه
كان في مشاهد تظهر في شخصيات مفاجاه
شخصيات خياليه يعني دمج بين الخيال
الصعب للمتابعه حتى دقيقه همم شوفي اهم
شيء انا لالي بكل عمل
مسرح هو السيناريو اهم شيء يكون لممثل
مقتنع باللي عم يمثله وحتى اذا في شخصيات
يمكن خياليه يمكن في اصوات بالراس يمكن
انا عم بس شيء مش موجود هذا شيء كثير صعب
اهم شيء الممثل الثاني
وبعدين المشاهد وهو بيصير يتلزز فيهن هول
اللحظات
والمخرج خلينا نحكي كمان مخرج بيطلع مرات
يا احلى ما في الممثل او اسوء ما في
الممثل يعني في بعض الاحيان اليوم هل كان
في مثلا يوسف او سفني صراع مثلا مع المخرج
انه انتم يعني تحمستوا كثير بالدور راح
تطلعوا خارج النص ولا كان لازم انا لا
التزم بالكلمات التزم بهذه الطريقه
[موسيقى]
هذا الموضوع ولما يشوفوا انه الممثل يمكن
بعد بيرجعوا بيردوه هو هذا المخرج كثير
مهم كل الاعمال انه هو يضلوا مسيطر على
الخبريه كلها بالاجمال طيب وكلمه اخيره
بتحبوا هيك توجهها لمن لم يحضر فيلم فرح
انا اكيد بديعيهم انه يحضروا لانه عمل همم
حلو فريق عملي كبير اشتغل عليه في مزيج
همم من اشخاص مختلفين كثير اجتمعنا لحتى
نقد عمل من كل قلبنا وعمل انتبه نحن عم
نشتغل انترتين يعني هذا سينما بدكم تروحوا
على السنه لا تنبسطوا وقت حلو يمكن تاخذه
منه رساله حلوه فاكيد بتمنى يحضروا
ويعجبني وانا كمان
عمل بكثير حب والعمل بكثير فرح العمل
بكثير الظروف
قطعتهاش اول يوم بالثوره في لبنان فتخيلوا
تشالنجر
فبيستاهل
اولا والجوائز اللي حصل
في الروائي شكرا جزيلا فرح ستيفاني عطا
الله الممثله